the analysis of responses to cancer  therapies in preclinical systems for  example cell lines have had some  challenges with reproducibility between  different sites conversely the sort of  gold standard of data being how if  cancer therapies are the distribution of  cancer therapies effects in human  clinical trial data a large well powered  trials have asked reproducible data and  there are very well-developed  statistical methods for the analysis if  they do from those human clinical trials  although these bio statistical methods  operated delving into the question of  mechanism of action and so from the  question of applying of computational  models to understand drug mechanism  clinical failure of cancer therapies I  would say this is not so much an area  ended by challenges so much as one  opened a great opportunities today